اسعد الله اوقاتكم بكل خير اهلا بكم الى
نشره الرابعه من الرياض وهذه ابرز عناوين
اليوم
بعد عمليه غزه اسرائيل تنشر بطاريات القبه
الحديديه وتؤكد استعدادها لكل سيناروهات
الحكومه الباكستانيه تقول بان اعتقال
عمران خان مرتبط بغسيل اموال وحزبه يطالب
باغلاق البلاد
وحمله بمواد طبيه وغذائيه وايوائيه بدء
تسير رحلات الجسر الاغاثي السعودي الى
السودان
في الرابعه ايضا
مكافحه المخدرات السعوديه تطيح بثمانيه
وعشرين مروجا لماده الشبو المخدره خلال
اسبوعين
نقلا عن وكاله الانباء الفرنسيه ليونيل
ميسي يلعب في الدوري السعودي العام المقبل
حياكم الله افاد مراسل العربيه بان الجيش
الاسرائيلي اجلى الاف المستوطنين من
مستوطنات محيطي غزه وسط تاهب القوات
الاسرائيليه على الحدود مع القطاع وذلك
بعد الغارات التي شنتها فجر اليوم وقتلت
فيها 13 فلسطينيا بينهم ثلاثه من قاده
حركه الجهاد مسؤول استخباراتي اكد للقناه
الثانيه عشره الاسرائيليه ان عمليه غزه
استهدفت حركه الجهاد وليس حماس مضيفا انهم
مستعدون لكل سيناريوهات في غزه بما في ذلك
الحرب المطوله وفي حال قررت حماس الانضمام
لرد حركه الجهاد جاء هذا عقب انتهاء جلسه
المشاورات الامنيه بين رئيس الوزراء
بنيامين نتنياهو ووزير الدفاع الاسرائيلي
يواب كلنت ومسؤوليه الاستخبارات لتقييم
الوضع الامني
ومن غزه ينضم الينا الصحفي محمد عوض مرحبا
بك محمد معي في هذه النشره الوضع الامني
الان في غزه كيف يمكن الحديث عنه بعد هذه
الغارات والتصعيد الاسرائيلي في القطاع
منذ ليله البارحه
باحاله الترقب التي تحولت الى القلق
والانتظار خاصه
في اللحظه الفصائل الفلسطينيه لم تقدم على
اي رد على الميزان رغم ان هذا المشهد غير
مالوف الا ان يبدو ان الفصائل في غزه عبر
الغرفه المشتركه التي تجمع حماس والجهاز
الاسلامي وباقي الفصائل العسكريه المسلحه
يبدو انها تستخدم استراتيجيه جديده وهي
اشغال الطرف
الاخر من جانب ومن جانب اخر عمليه
الاستنزاف خاصه وان الجيش او عزالي
المستوطنين الذين يسكنون في غلاف غزه وعلى
بعد 30 كيلو من قطاع غزه المنطقه وعدم
التعرض الى للضروره القصوى وابلاغ الان
بالمنطقه وعلى هذا الحال عمليه الاشغال
وعمليه الاستنزاف التي يعني
الفلسطينيه هي من شانها
في ان تشغل الشاشه الاسرائيليون الذين
ينتظرون كيف ستبدا الفصائل الفلسطينيه في
غزه
اغتيال عدد كبير من المواطنين في قطاع هل
هناك سيناريو
كيف يمكن ان ترد هذه الفصائل هل يمكن ان
ترد بشكل موحد بمعنى ان تكون حماس جزءا من
هذا الرد ام ستكتفي حركه الجهاد بالرد فقط
على ما طالها من هذا الهجوم باستهداف
ثلاثه
اليوم هو يعني خارج توقعات اسرائيل بان
توقعت انها ستستفرد بالجهاز الاسلامي وان
الجهاد الاسلامي سيطبق الصواريخ اتجاه
البلدات الاصليه كما حدث في المناطق
السابقه لكن مع بيان الغرفه المشتركه اسدل
الغطاء او ازدل الستار عن ما ستؤول اليه
الاوضاع في قطاع غزه الجميع ملتزم بقرار
الغرفه المشتركه التابعه للفصائل العسكريه
المسلحه في قطاع غزه بما فيها حماس اي
بمعنى ان التصعيد في قطاع غزه
فتح حماس والجهاد وكل الفصائل والاضواء
العسكريه المسلحه هذا من جانب من جانب اخر
تحديد الجيش الاسرائيلي لان بعد عمليه
الاغتلاء الاغتيال قام الطيران الاسرائيلي
بقصف مواقع مركزيه وحساسه تدفع للجهاز
الاسلامي وهذا
يهدف الى جر الجهاد الاسلامي في تصعيد
لوحده كما حدث في المرات السابقه حين
اغتالت اسرائيل بهاء ابو العطا وتيسير
الجعبري
اخر لكن اليوم الفصائل الفلسطينيه خرجت في
بيان موحد واحد وبيان مختلط وسريع صنعى
الشهداء وتقول بانهم
مناسب وهذا على حد ما جاء في البيان يعني
ان الرد الذي ستنفذه المقاومه او المقاومه
في غزه هو رد مبني على الاتفاق الفلسطيني
من خلال العذراء العسكريه التي تشارك في
غرفه العمليات المشتركه التي
تدرس الصينيه في
غزه شكرا جزيلا لك من غزه انضم الينا
الصحفي محمد عوض شكرا لك
الان الى كلمه الوزير الخارجيه السعوديه
الامير فيصل ابن فرحان والذي يزور الجزائر
في هذه الاثناء
كثيرا تواجد اليوم في الجمهوريه الجزائريه
الديمقراطيه الشعبيه ولقائي بخامه الرئيس
عبد المجيد تبون وتشرفت بنقل تحيات سيدي
خادم الحرمين الشريفين والسيد سمول العهد
الامير محمد بن سلمان بن عبد العزيز
لفخامته ولا الشعب الجزائري الشقيق زياره
اليوم تاتي استكمالا واستمرارا للتعاون
والتنسيق
الوطيد بين المملكه العربيه السعوديه
والجزائر في كافه الامور وفي هذه الزياره
بالذات فيما يتعلق بالشان العربي باعتبار
الجزائر هي رئيسه القمه العربيه الحاليه
والمملكه العربيه السعوديه ستستلم ان شاء
الله الرئاسه في الفتره القادمه وقد وجدت
كالعاده توافق تام في الرؤى بين المملكه
العربيه السعوديه والجزائر
وقد استشعرت من فخامه الرئيس حرصه على
المضي قدما في كافه مجالات التعاون بين
بلدينا على المستوى الثنائي وهناك فرص
كثيره في هذا الاطار بالذات في تعزيز
التبادل التجاري هناك ارتفاع مضطرد خلال
السنوات الماضيه ونرى فرص لتعزيز هذا
الاستمرار في بحث مجالات التنسيق والتعاون
الاخرى ولا شك ان التعاون والتنسيق على
المستوى الثنائي والمتعدد بين الجزائر
والمملكه يخدم ليس فقط بلدينا لكن امن
واستقرار العالم العربي ومنطقتنا بشكل
الاوسع
والمجتمع الدولي كاملا فسنستمر ان شاء
الله في هذا التعاون والتنسيق وشكرا
اذا كانت هذه الكلمه لوزير الخارجيه
السعودي الامير فيصل ابن فرحان والذي يزور
الجزائر هذه الايام قال بان التعاون بين
بلدينا يخدم استقرار المنطقه في هذه
الكلمه التي تابعنا واياكم قبل قليل على
شاشه العربيه العوده الى الرابعه ادان
منسق الامم المتحده الخاص لعمليه السلامه
في الشرق الاوسط مقتل مدنيين في الغارات
الاسرائيليه على غزه داعيا جميع الاطراف
المعنيه الى ممارسه اقصى درجات ضبط النفس
وقال في حسابه على تويتر انه لا يزال على
تواصله مع كل الاطراف في مسعى لتجنب نشوب
صراع اوسع ذي تداعيات مدمره
الحكومه الفلسطينيه من جانبها وصفت الهجوم
الاسرائيلي على غزه بانه ارهاب دوله منظمه
وقال رئيس الوزراء الفلسطيني محمد شتيه في
بيان ان حكومه نتنياهو تحاول تصدير الازمه
الداخليه بشانها على قطاع غزه وترسيخ
عقليه التطرف التي تتحكم في قراراتها وطلب
اشتيا الامم المتحده بادانه العدوان على
القطاع وتوحيد المعايير في التعامل مع
الجرائم التي يرتكبها قاده اسرائيل وعدم
السماح لهم بالافلات من العقاب
كما ادانت مصر في بيان التصعيد
الاسرائيليه في الاراضي الفلسطينيه بقيام
القوات الاسرائيليه بقصف قطاع غزه ما اسفر
عن 13 ضحيه وعشرين مصابا حتى الان بينهم
نساء واطفال كما ادان البيان ايضا اقتحام
مجموعه من المستوطنين للمسجد الاقصى صباح
اليوم تحت حمايه القوات الاسرائيليه
بالاضافه الى استمرار الاقتحامات للمدن
الفلسطينيه اخرها نابلس اكد البيان على
رفض مصر الكامل لمثل تلك الاعتداءات التي
تتنافى مع قواعد القانون الدولي واحكام
الشرعيه الدوليه
ذلك كشفت مصادر مطلعه للعربيه ان القاهره
تجري اتصالات موسعه لمنع تصعيد الاوضاع في
قطاع غزه القاهره كانت حذرت اسرائيل منذ
اسبوع الفصائل في غزه من عمليات اغتيال
اسرائيليه تستهدف قاده فيها من جهتها
ابلغت الفصائل الفلسطينيه الوسطاء انها
سترد على عمليات الاغتيال الاسرائيليه
التي انهت التهدئه التي تم الاتفاق عليها
قبل ايام فيما ابلغت اسرائيل الوسطاء
بانتهاء عمليتها العسكريه بشكل مؤقت عقب
الهجمات العسكريه ضد اهداف لحركه الجهاد
بغزو فجر اليوم
[موسيقى]
وسنعود طبعا لمتابعه هذا الملف مع مراسل
العربيه في فلسطين زياد حلبي للوقوف على
اخر التطورات على المستوى الميداني وعلى
المستوى السياسي ايضا كذلك والاجتماعات
الامنيه الاسرائيليه التي كانت قد عقدت
منذ ظهر اليوم مباشره من حدود قطاع غزه
مدير مكتب العربيه في فلسطين زياد حلبي
زياد مرحبا بك معي في نشره الرابعه من
الرياض زياد كيف تبدو الامور على الحدود
حتى هذه اللحظه مستوى التاخب كيف يمكن
رصده كذلك ايضا نشر البطاريات القبه
الحديديه منذ ظهور اليوم
هذا صحيح الانتظار هو سمه الموقف بمعنى
هناك حال ترقب وحال توتر شديده جدا على
جبهه قطاع غزه لم تتمثل فقط في نشر عشرات
بطاريات القبه الحديديه من حدود قطاع غزه
وحتى حدود لبنان وانما ايضا باجلاء الاف
المستوطنين عن المستوطنات الحدوديه
القريبه من قطاع غزه تباعا منذ صباح هذا
اليوم وحتى الان جرى اجراء نحو ثلاثه الاف
مستوطن عن هذه المستوطنات
الى وسط وشمال اسرائيل هناك حال انتظار
الان من الاسرائيليين لمعرفه طبيعه وحجم
وعمق الرد المتوقع من قطاع غزه كما اسلاف
فعلا هناك توالي للاجتماعات الامنيه اخرها
كان اجتماع وزير الدفاع مع هيئه الاركان
الاسرائيليه في مقر وزاره الدفاع حيث تقرر
طبعا الرد على الرد الفلسطيني عندما ياتي
بغارات تستهدف مواقع للجهاد الاسلامي
والفصائل الاخرى وحباس طبعا
حاليا سعيد امام سؤال هل ستشارك حماس في
الرد وما هو حجم وطبيعه هذا الرد بمعنى هل
سيبدا باستهداف تل ابيب ومطار تل ابيب
وباطلاق عشرات الصواريخ دفعه واحده ام
بشكل اخر حتى الساعه لا اجابه عن هذا
الموضوع طيب قبل قليل طبعا مسؤول اسرائيلي
كان قد ذكر ليدعوت احرنوت بانه بان
اسرائيل لا تريد تصعيدا في غزه لكنها
تترقب الرد وهنا مالات الرد المتوقعه
بالنسبه لاسرائيل من خلال اجتماعاتها سواء
اجتماعيه الاركان مع وزير الدفاع وايضا
الاجتماعات التي قادها رئيس الوزراء
اليوم ما هي الصوره المتوقعه لدى اسرائيل
على الاقل زياد
وهناك اجتماع ايضا للحكومه الامنيه
المصغره الامني عند السابع مساء مساء بعد
نحو ثلاث ساعات من الان نعم مساء للبحث في
التصعيد الحاصل لكن القرار لم يتخذ في هذه
الحكومه المصغره وانما يتخذ في مطبخ ضيق
من وزير الدفاع ومستشار الامن القومي
وقاده الجيش واجهزه الاستخبارات والامن
ونتنياهو هذا هو المطبخ الذي يقرر الامر
العملياتي بعيدا عن وزراء غير مجربين
امنيا مثل بنجفير وسمودريتش والموزراء
المتدينين الاخرين في الحكومه المصغره
بالتالي القرار عمليا هو الرد على
السيناريوهات محتمله تبدا بتصعيد محدود
بمعنى يوم او يومين من القتال على جبهه
قطاع غزه وصولا الى حرب شامله تشارك فيها
كل الفصائل الفلسطينيه وقد تكون ايضا
تصعيد متعدد الجبهات بمعنى اطلاق صواريخ
من لبنان وسوريا
التصعيد في الضفه الغربيه المحتله وما الى
ذلك كل هذه السيناريوات بحثت وبحث الرد في
على كل منها على كل سيناريو ما احتمل منها
لكن حاليا الانتظار هو كما قلت والترقب
سمات الموقف لا احد يعرف حقا ما تبيته
الفصائل على المستوى الداخلي في اسرائيل
ايضا كذلك زياد الى اي مدى دقيق من يقول
بان هذه رشوه سياسيه قدمها نتنياهو للداخل
الاسرائيلي
ليس للداخل الاسرائيلي وانما للقاعده
اليمنيه الغاضبه والمتراجعه شعبيا في
الداخل الاسرائيلي هذا قد يكون جزئيا صحيح
بمعنى هناك ازمه داخليه عميقه جدا في
اسرائيل بنيامين نتنياهو يعرف بان
استطلاعات الراي لا تكذب على ماده ثلاثه
اشهر هناك انهيار في شعبيه نتنياهو واحزاب
اليمين ككل في كل استطلاعات الراي بسبب
محاولات الانقلاب على نظام القضاء
وبالتالي قد يكون هذا في الاعتباراته
عمليا راينا بنجفير يقاطع الحكومه ويقاطع
التصويت في الكنيست بسبب ما وصفه هزاله
الرد على قطاع غزه الثلاثاء الماضي فقط
وبالتالي الان سيعود الى احضان نتنياهو
اليمين وبالاضافه الى ذلك الان لا توجد
انتقادات لاداء الحكومه بالعكس
الاعلام الاسرائيلي في مثل هذه الحالات
يكون مجندا بالكامل لصالح العمل العسكري
لا ينتقد اعتبارات او اداء الحكومه والجيش
على الارض وهذا طبعا بيت القصيد بالنسبه
اشكرك جزيل الشكر من حدود قطاع غزه مدير
مكتب العربيه في فلسطين زياد حلب شكرا
جزيلا لك
طلب حزب رئيس الوزراء السابق عمران خان
انصاره باغلاق باكستان ردا على اعتقاله
وذكرت وزاره الداخليه الباكستانيه ان
عمران خان تم اعتقاله على خلفيه عمليات
غسل اموال تصل الى 190 مليون جنيه
استرليني والحصول على اراضي بشكل غير
قانوني واثارت محاوله اعتقال عمران خان في
وقت سابق احتجاجات واشتباكات بين الشرطه
وانصاري لكنه ينفي كافه الاتهامات ضده
بالفساد ويعتبر القضايا مسيسه
[موسيقى]
تابعوا اياكم هذه الصور المباشره من
كراتشي لاندلاع اعمال شغب عقب اعتقال رئيس
الحكومه الباكستاني السابق عمران خان
والذي تم ايقافه اثناء مثوله امام محكمه
في اسلام اباد من قبل طبعا عملاء مكتب
المحاسبه الوطني وهي الهيئه المنوطه
بمكافحه الفساد في
باكستاني اذا هذه صور لاندلاء اعمال شغفي
كراتشي عقبى اعتقال عمران خان كما نشاهد
واياكم في القسم الايمن من الصوره امامنا
مباشره الى اسلام اباد من هناك مراسل
العربيه عبد الرحمن المزيني عبد الرحمن
مرحبا بك ما هي حيثيات ايقاف عمران خانه
التي يمكن الاستناد عليها قانونيه
وفق وزير الداخليه الباكستاني رانا سناء
الله فان عمليه اعتقال رئيس وزراء السابق
عمران خان تمت بناء على مذكره توقيف
اصدرها مكتب المحاسبه الوطني في بدايه هذا
الشهر عمران خان كان هناك عده مذكرات تم
ارسالها الى عنوانه في العاصمه اسامه في
مدينه لاغور لكن عمران خان لم
يستجب الى هذه الدعوات له بالمسؤول امام
المحققين في عدد من قضايا الفساد ولعل من
ابرزها قضيه وقف خيري قال وزير الداخليه
بانه
كلف خزينه الدوله نحو 190 مليون جنيه
استرليني بالاضافه الى الاستحواذ على
اراضي تابعه للدوله بطريقه غير قانونيه
هذه ربما هي القش الذي التي قسمت
ظهر البعير وربما هذه هي القضيه كما يؤكد
وزير الداخليه الباكستاني بانها هي السبب
ورائع اعتقاله هذه القضيه تضاف الى عشرات
القضايا والبلاغات التي يواجهها رئيس
الوزراء السابق عمران خان عمران خان تحدث
على انه يواجه اكثر من 150 قضيه وبلاغ
تتعلق باتهامات بالفساد والارهاب والشغب
والاساءه الى بعض المؤسسات هنا في باكستان
لكن عمران خان يؤكد بان هذه القضايا كلها
وهذه البلاغات ضده قضايا مسيسه وتستند الى
ادله واهيه وانها لا تستند الى حقائق يمكن
ان تثبت امام القضاء هذا الامر كيف انعكس
على الشارع الباكستاني نحن نشاهد صور مثلا
من كراتشي اشتباكات كذلك ايضا اعمال شغب
هل هذا فقط في كراتشي ام في بقيه المدن
الباكستانيه ولا ماذا هناك تخوف من
انعكاسات ما حدث لعمر
[موسيقى]
لا شك يبدو ان الاوضاع في باكستان تتجه
الى التصعيد خرج انصار رئيس الوزراء
السابق في العديد من
المدن الباكستانيه والبلدات الباكستانيه
تراوحت الاعداد بين المئات والالاف ربما
ابرز هذه المظاهرات والاحتجاجات وفي مدينه
كراتشي وفي مدينه لاهور تخلل هذه
المظاهرات في بعض المناطق اغلاق الطرق
واشعال
اطارات سيارات واشعال الحرائق واغلاق عدد
من مفارق الطرق الرئيسيه السلطات
الباكستانيه هنا في العاصمه وفي مدينه
لاغور قامت
بفرض الماده
144 وهي تتعلق بحذر التجمهور لاكثر من
خمسه اشخاص
الوضع يمكن القول بانه يتجه الى التصعيد
وهناك حاله من المخاوف من خروج الاوضاع عن
السيطره لاسيما وان الرئيس الوزراء السابق
عمران خان حذر من انه لم يعد ربما يمتلك
المقدره على السيطره على الحشود فيما لو
تم اعتقاله او ربما اغتياله كما صرح في
وقت سابق طيب
لازلنا نتابع واياكم مشاهدينا هذه الصور
اسفل الشاشه كما ذكرنا قبل قليل لاندلاع
اعمال الشغب في كراتشي عقب اعتقال رئيس
الوزراء الباكستاني السابق عمران خان اشكر
الزميل عبد الرحمن بن زيد مراسل العربيه
من اسلام مبادئ على كل هذه التفاصيل
والمعلومات
انطلقت اليوم من الرياض اولى طلائع طائرات
الجسر الجويه لغاتي السعودي لمساعده الشعب
السوداني هذا وتحمل الطائرتين عشرين طنا
من المساعدات الغذائيه والايوائيه والطبيه
التي ستصل الى مطار بورسودان لاستقبال
اولى المساعدات السعوديه
مراسل العربيه عبد المحسن الحربي ينضم
الينا من الرياض عبد المحسن مرحبا بك معي
في نشره الرابعه من الرياض من التفاصيل
المتوفره لديك حول هذه الطائرتين الثاني
تقلع الى بورتسودان
نعم نايف بالفعل قبل قليل وفي خلفه طائره
الاولى التي حملت او وضعت كافه حمولتها
التي تم وضعها بداخل الطائره من مساعدات
اغاثيه وغذائيه ودوائيه وكذلك ايوائيه
بهذه الطائره التي تستعد الان للاقلاع من
مطار الملك خالد الدولي وتحديدا منطقه
الشحن في عبراده الطائره العسكريه التي
حملت هذه المساعدات مباشره وتنطلق الان في
اولى طلائع الجسر الجويه السعودي الذي تم
اطلاقه اليوم رسميا عبر هذه الطائره
وسيستمر لايام واسابيع وبحسب تصريحات
مسؤوليه مركز الملك سلمان فما دام الحاجه
للشعب السوداني ان هنالك مزيد من الاحتياج
بخصوص هذه المساعدات سيتم او سيبقى سيبقى
هذا الجسر ممتدا لاسابيع واشهر قادمه حتى
ان يتم ايصال المساعدات لكافه
المحتاجين وكذلك الاماكن الاكثر تضررا
سواء كان من ناحيه غذائيه او من ناحيه
دوائيه ناحيه ايضا طبيه وحتى على مستوى
الكوادر حيث اعلى المركز الملك سلمان عن
افتتاح او دعوه لكافه الكوادر الطبيه
للتطوع عبر احد المنصات الرسميه وبذلك قدم
الالاف ربما من
كوادر الصحيه السعوديه وهم ينتظرون فرصه
للذهاب الى السودان هذه الطائره الاولى لم
تحمل فقط المساعدات الغذائيه والدوائيه
والطبيه والايوائيه نايف بل الحمله ايضا
وركب على متنها بعدد من مسؤولين مركز
الملك سلمان الذين سيعملون على الاشراف
بشكل مباشر على توزيع هذه المساعدات في
بورت سودان عبر التعاون مع احد المتعاهدين
وكذلك المنظمات الدوائيه الغازيه
السودانيه التي تعمل بالداخل وب كمرحله
اولى سيتم توزيع هذه المساعدات على
النازحين في الداخل بشكل رئيسي ويبلغ
عددهم على ما يقرب 300 الى 400 الف ناجح
في الداخل السوداني بالاض الى ما يقرب 60
الف في دول الجوار واكثر من ذلك بحسب
الاحصائيات والتاشيره المؤشرات التقديريه
بالاضافه الى ذلك سيكون هنالك نايف بعد
اقل من ساعتين طائره اخرى هي الطائره
الثانيه على هذا
بخلال هذا اليوم وبحسب جدول الجسر الاغاثه
عبر يومه الاول ستكون الطائره ايضا ستحمل
على متنها عشره اطنان من المساعدات
الاغاثيه والغذائيه والدوائيه والطبيه
التي ستذهب مباشره الى مطار بورت سودان
على ان تستمر هذه العمليه خلال الايام
القادمه بالاضافه لذلك سيكون هنالك ايضا
جسرا موازيا للجسر الجوي وهواء الجسر
البحري الذي سيتم الاستعداد او يتم
الاستعداد حاليا على اطلاقه خلال ربما
الايام القليله القادمه نايف اشكرك جزيل
الشكر عبد المحسن الحربي مراسل العربيه من
العاصمه السعوديه الرياض شكرا جزيلا لك
وكشفت اداره المطارات مطارات جدا عن
استقبال وتوديع اكثر من اربعه ملايين
مسافر اقلتهم 28 الف رحله خلال موسم
العمره من جهتها تواصل وزاره الحج والعمره
متابعه اوضاع المعتبرين السودانيين في
السعوديه لتسهيل اجراءات عودتهم الى
البلاد
من مطار الملك عبد العزيز الدولي بجده
ينضم الينا مراسل عربيه السلطان السلمي
سلطان مرحبا بك معي في نشره الرابعه من
الرياض سلطانه ابرز الارقام المعلومات
ايضا فيما يتعلق بعدد الرحلات التي غادرت
من مطار جده الى وجهات مختلفه وتتعلق ايضا
بمن وصلوا الى مكه المكرمه
اهلا بك نايف اهلا بكافه مشاهدي قناه
العربيه من مطار الملكه عبد العزيز الدولي
بجده هذا المنفذ الجوي المهم والذي يشكل
70% من نسبه القدوم والمغادره لمن رغبه
باداء مناسك العمره منذ بدء موسم العمره
منذ بدايه العام الهجنه تحدث عن اعداد
وارقام كبيره سجلها هذا المنفذ الجوي
المهم نتحدث عن اكثر من 30 مليون رحله
قدوم ومغادره منذ بدء موسم
العمرانيات المغادره والقدوم هنا داخل هذه
الصاله صاله رقم واحد وهي من ضمن عدد
ومجموعه من صالات القدوم والمغادره هنا
بمطار الملك عبد العزيز الدولي بجده فيما
يتعلق بابرز الارقام المتعلقه بموسم
العمره تحدثنا منذ واحد تسعه لعام 1444
وتحديدا من واحد رمضان وحتى العاشر من
شوال سجل اكثر من اربعه اربعه مليون و400
الف مسافر وكذلك بين ومغادره نتحدث عن عدد
رحلات وصلت الى 28 الف رحله نتحدث عن سبعه
فاصله تسعه مليون حقيبه ايضا يتحدث عنها
ارقام الشحن الجوي نتحدث على 30 الف طن في
هذه المرحله او في هذا التاريخ من واحد
رمضان وحتى العاشر من شوائب بلغ اعلى معدل
تشغيل المطار في اليوم الواحد 143 الف
مسافر وتحديدا في العاشر من رمضان الموافق
الاول من شهر ابريل طبعا اعتمدت هذه الخطه
التشغيليه لموسم هذه العمره اختلفت بشكل
كبير جدا عن كافه المواسم الماضيه نتحدث
عن وضع السيناريوهات كبيره وعددها يصل الى
27 سيناريو لاي ازمه محتمله قد تحصل اثناء
موسم العمره نتحدث عن وضع خطط تشغيليه
تتناسب وضع خطط تشغيليه مع كافه القطاعات
الامنيه والتشغيليه وكذلك الخاص ايضا
نتحدث عن توفير اعداد كبيره من العاملين
داخل المطار منذ بدء موسم العمره تتحدث عن
عدد اجمالي يصله 30 مليون مسافر قدوم
ومغادره و176 الف رحله وتم مناوله خمسين
مليون حقيبه منذ بدايه شهر محرم للعام
الهجري فيما يتعلق بعمليات الاجلال
ومغادره الرعايه وتحديدا من الجاليه او من
الجنسيه السودانيه نتحدث عن اكثر وغيرها
من الجنسيات من بعد ان تم اجلؤه من
السودان الى مدينه جده عبر قاعده الملك
فيصل البحريه بجده وحتى عبر قاعده الملك
عبد الله الجويه وكذلك عبر بناء جده
الاسلامي نتحدث عن اكثر من 3560 مواطن
باختلاف جنسيتهم عبر اربعه عشر رحله من
جده كانت الى الصين واليمن والهند فيما
يتعلق بالمعتمرين السودانيين بداوا بالفعل
المغادره منذ قرابه الاربعه ايام عبر
شركتين للخطوط وهي شركه تاركو الهنديه
شركه تاركو السودانيه وكذلك شركه الخطوط
السودانيه شركه البدو نتحدث على سبيل
المثال فيما يتعلق بشركه تاركو تم تخصيص
اربع رحلات يوميه وهي في تمام الساعه
الخامسه فجرا والساعه السابعه مساء
والساعه مساء والساعه الثانيه عشره بعد
منتصف الليل على كل رحله من هذه الاربعه
رحلات التي تستمر حتى 30 مايو على متنها
120 لا تزال عمليات المغادره مستمره
لمختلف الجنسيات فيما يتعلق بالمعتمرين
عمليات مستمره منذ ايام تم تسهيل وضع
تسهيلات وايضا تكثيف الجهود فيما يتعلق
بعمليات المغادره موضع كافه الخدمات لهم
ايضا التحدث عن القائم الكبيره وايضا
يغادرون هؤلاء الرعايه او هؤلاء المعتمرين
عبر صالات مجمع صالات الحج والعمره نعم
كل هذه المعلومات والارقام تفصيليه
والدقيقه من مطار الملك عبد العزيز الدولي
بجده مراسل العربيه السلطان السلام يا
سلطان
قال المتحدث الرسمي لقوات التحالف العربي
لدعم الشرعي في اليمن العميد التركي
المالكي للعربيه قال ان تطبيق القانون
الدولي الانساني
ركيزه اساسيه في العمليات العسكريه وذلك
على هامشي فعاليه يوم القانون الدولي
الانساني المقام في الرياض كما ذكرت ركيزه
اساسيه تطبيق القانون الدولي الانساني في
العمليات العسكريه هناك التزام قانوني
اخلاقي تجاه اي عمليات عسكريه
طورنا الكثير في مجال التدريب لسواء كان
المخططين او حتى المنفدين وهذه من
الاجراءات التي اسهمت في العمليات
العسكريه واحترام
المدنيين ايضا وما يكون هناك اي اضرار
جانبيه
رابع مستمر وفيها بعد قليل
صحيفه الشرق الاوسط تطلق تطويرا شاملا
لمنصاتها على شبكه الانترنت
حياكم الله من جديد كشف حساب ومكافحه
المخدرات السعوديه على تويتر عن الاطاحه
بثمانيه وعشرين متورطا في الترويج لماده
الشبو في عده مناطق خلال الخمسه عشر يوما
الماضيه كان اخرها خلال الاربع والعشرين
ساعه الماضيه حيث تم القبض على مقيمين
اثنين لترويجهما ماده الشبو المقدره
بمنطقه تبوك كما تم ايقاف اربعه مقيمين من
الجنسيه الباكستانيه للترويجهم اكثر من 24
كيلو جراما من ماده الشبو في المنطقه
الشرقيه الامن العام السعودي اعلن اليوم
كذلك عبر حسابه على تويتر عن القبض على
مقيم من الجنسيه البنغلاديشيه لترويجه
ايضا ماده الشبو المخدره
في يعني من اهم وسائل الحمايه من
التعاطف مخدرات بشكل كامل هو خفض الطلب
وخفض العرض الجهود الامنيه تهتم بخفض
العرض يعني في هذا الجانب ونشهد كما جهد
جباره في هذا الجانب الاهم والاقوى وكما
توصي المنظمات الدوليه
الابرز والاكثر
اهميه هو خفض الطلب وهو الوقايه من تعاطي
المخدرات وجعل الافراد قادرين باذن الله
عز وجل على كسب الحصانه تجاه هذه الافه
والبعد عنها قدر الامكان تعادل مخدرات هي
عافه تعم جامع جميع الشعوب العالم
لا يستثنى منها احد لكن كيف نحمي انفسنا
وابنائنا منها هذا هو يعني هدف المشروع
الوطني الوقايه من المخدرات نبراس
بتعزيز يعني المساهمه بتعزيز المجتمع
اتجاه هذه
الافه وكيف وش اللي قدمه يا دكتور
البرنامج في انه
للاسر في انهم يتعاملوا مع افراد العائله
سواء الافراد العائله المتعاطين لا سمح
الله او كذلك محاوله المحافظه عليهم
الوقايه ايضا كذلك من
انخراط في مثل هذه المواد المخدر القاتله
طيب النقطه
اهم اليوم هي المرحله ما قبل التعاطي وهذه
اغلب جهودنا مركز على هذا الجانب رقم جهود
الموجوده في كل الجوانب مرحله ما قبل
التعاطي هي تعزيز حصانه الانسان او الطفل
تحديده والابناء تجاه هذه المخدرات وعدم
ورفضها وعدم حتى مجرد التفكير بتعاطيها من
خلال اعداد برامج ووسائل
ومواد علميه وايضا
بودكاستات وغيرها والعاب وغيرها مكرسه
لجانبك تعزيز مهارات الوالدين تجاه تعاطي
المخدرات وكيفيه حمايه ابنائهم من تعاطيها
وذلك من خلال
يعني غرس يعني قيمه لدى الاباء ان تعاطي
الوقايه متعاطي المخدراتك من خلال تنميه
فرد سوي على جميع المستويات اليوم
الوقايه من التعاطي المخدرات ليست من خلال
تقديم ماده وهذه عينه يا ابني شوفها هذه
ما ينصح تتعاطاها لا مو بالطريقه هذه فقط
الطريقه يعني دكتور تغيرت تطورت طرق
التوعيه تجارب الدراسات العلميه وايضا
توصيات المنظمه الدوليه في هذا الجانب تحث
على ان نركز على التنشئه
والتربيه السويه اولا
طبعا
ضعف الوعي بخطوره هالماده قاد الى التوجه
كثير من المتعاطين الى تعاطينها يمكن هذا
احد الاسباب والعوامل ايضا عدم الادراك
يعني بعض الناس لما تجي تقول له مخدرات
وماده تصنفها بعنوانها بعنوان صحيح
يخاف منها لكن لما تاتي بمصطلحات من خلال
جلسات بعض الاصدقاء وضعف قدره انسان زي مع
اسلفت انه على تعاطيها هنا يكون خلل اليوم
قد تكون ماده مثل الشبو لكن ممكن لا قدر
الله مستقبل تظهر مواد اخرى في عالم
المخدرات مصنعي وعصابات المخدرات كل يوم
تظهر تصنع ماده جديده وتحاول ان تغسل
المجتمعات فيها فهدفنا من خلال برنامج
البراز تحديدا انه نعزل الحصان مجتمعيه
اتجاه جميع المواد بما فيها الشبوه وغيرها
من المواد ايضا من خلال بعض البرامج
المختصه بمناقشه الافكار المغلوطه يعني من
خلال التواصل الاجتماعي عندنا موجود حلقات
خاصه لمناقشه بعض الافكار اللي تروج لبعض
المواد المخدره اشكرك جزيل الشكر الدكتور
سليمان اختصاصي للوقايه من المخدرات التي
اداره المشروع الوطني للوقايه من المخدرات
شكرا جزيلا لك يا دكتور
اعلنت صحيفه الشرق الاوسط عن تطوير الرقمي
المتكامله لمنصاتها وحساباتها المختلفه
ونسختها المطبوعه الصحيفه اشارت الى ان
ذلك التطوير يعد تعزيزا لمكانتها في
المشهد الاعلامي ولمواكبه الانماط
المتغيره لاستهلاك الاخبار عبر منصات
محدثه ما يسهم في اتاحه المحتوى محتوى
الشرق الاوسط على برامج منصات المجموعه
السعوديه للابحاث والاعلام هذا منطلقت
صحيفه الشرق الاوسط عام
1978 كصحيفه عربيه دوليه تلبي متطلبات
القراء العرب في مختلف اسواق العالم
واشتهرت منذ بداياتها بموقعها في شارع
الصحافه في لندن
ومن لندن ينضم الينا مساعد رئيس تحرير
صحيفه الشرق الاوسط صحفي زيد بن كمي سيد
زيد مساء الخير حياك الله معي في نشره
الرابعه من الرياض نبارك لكم الحله
الجديده
لصحيفه الشرق الاوسط وخليني اسال بدايه ما
الذي اختلفت به الشرق الاوسط اليوم عن
شكلها القديم السابق
شكرا لك اخي نايف وشكرا لك التهنئه
والمباركة وايضا احنا نبارك ايضا لقراء
الشرق الاوسط من خلال قناه العربيه حدثنا
الشرق الاوسط يعني هي مدرسه بحد ذاتها
يعني لها اكثر من 45 سنه لديها يعني تاريخ
طويل جدا وتقوم دائما على دائما هي
الكواكب التطوير والتحديد دائما من اول
الصحف التي هي واكبت التطوير الطباعه
وايضا عن طريق الاقمار الصناعيه وايضا هي
من اول من استخدم من الصحف العربيه استخدم
الانترنت والان مسيرتها الشرق الاوسط في
عمليه التحديث والتطوير بشكل دائم مستمر
جدا احنا الان ح اصبحنا يعني اكثر توسعنا
بشكل كبير جدا في الموضوع الرقمي ايضا في
موضوع المطبوع بشكل يعني بشكل محدد لكن
المطلوع الرقمي اصبح نحن نوصل الى عن طريق
منصات يعني ملصقات متعدده احنا اصبحنا
الان ايضا كذلك توسع في موضوع الفيديو
وتوسع ايضا في الوثائقيات في ايضا ما
تحملت الشرق الاوسط من محتوى ثري جدا
حقيقه هي الشرق الاوسط تتميز بهذا المحتوى
فلذلك هو
الاستخدام هذه الوسائل
الادوات التي الان تستخدمها الشرق الاوسط
في السوشيال ميديا او سواء ايضا في الموقع
او ايضا كذلك السمعي او البصري فهذه كلها
الوسائل الرقميه التي اصبحنا رقمنا الشرق
الاوسط
لكن على مستوى المطبوع هناك في تحديث ايضا
كذلك على مستوى الصحيفه الورقيه وش اللي
تغير
الورقيه طبعا انا معي ان النسخه عدد اليوم
كذا شاهد الزملاء او الاخوان هذا عدد
اليوم حقيقه احنا ركزنا في العدد الورقي
انه يكون يعني اكثر احدا ايضا متواكب ايضا
مع تطوير رقم صحيفه الشرق الاوسط يكون
ايضا مريح للعيد واعتقد ان هذه يعني
التحول التي تحويل التحويل بشهادتها الشرق
الاوسط هو جزء ايضا من ما تقوم به
المجموعه السعوديه صار ضمن استراتيجيه
التحول لجميع المطبوعات من ضمنها الشرق
الاخر الاوسط التي تفعل المجموعه السعوديه
يعني مع هذا التحول والرقمنه ايضا للصحف
ليس على مستوى الشرق الاوسط فقط على على
اتكلم على كل النماذج التي تحولت وتركنت
يعني بشكل عصري وبشكل اي ايضا جديد يخشى
من ان يعني تفقد الصحافه شكلها التقليدي
او انواع الصحافه ايضا كذلك التقليدي
فياتي السؤال هل يمكن ان تؤثر هذه الرقمنه
على شكل الصحافه التقليديه على مبادئها
على ثوابتها ايضا الاساسيه والمعروفه منذ
100 السنين
مهم جدا في حياه الانسان وايضا في
المؤسسات واعتقد ان الشرق الاوسط الصحيفه
عريقه وايضا هي من اهم المؤسسات التي
دائما هي تواكب التطوير وهذا نوع من
التطوير تطوير والتحديث ايضا الوصول
للقراء اعتقد ان الان حتى يعني استهلاك
الاخبار واستهلاك المعلومات ايضا تغيرت
ايضا وسائل البحث عن المعلومات وعن
الاخبار وعن ايضا لتراء المعرفي
والمعلوماتي فلذلك المهم جدا ان وسائل
الاعلام انها ايضا تتوسع في الوصول الى
القراء وايصال المحتوى الذي تصنع هذه
المواسات الاعلاميه اعتقد
في قطار المستقبل انه سيبقى في الماضي
لذلك المهم جدا ان في ظني في تقديري انا
المؤسسات الاعلاميه او غير الاعلاميه انها
في ركب المستقبل ولا تتخلف عن هذا الركض
مش اللي تحتاجه اليوم الصحف على المستوى
العربي على المستوى الخليجي يعني حتى
تواكب العصر اليوم حتى تصبح صحافه جديده
صحافه فاعله تمارس دورها الصحفي كما ينبغي
لكنها تكون قريبه من المتلقي يعني خلينا
نقولها بصراحه لم يعد احد يقرا الورق هذا
اليوم الاغلب يقراونها بشكل مرقمان
سواء كان على الموقع او على التطبيقات
الموجوده ايضا كذلك لهذه الصحف والتي
بعضها تحول الى الى منصه صحفيه كامله ليست
فقط ورقيه
لديها الرغبه لديها اداره مهمه جدا ان
تقود هذا التحديث وهذا التطوير في
المؤسسات التي او المنصات التي تتبع
المجموعه واعتقد ان هذا مشهودا لمجموعه من
سنوات طويله جدا وهي الان الى الان تصير
هذه المسيره الشق الاخر اعتقد انه من
المهم جدا انه هو استخدام الوسائل او
التقنيه
استخدامها بشكل فعال جدا للوصول الى
القراء وصول الى الجمهور الجديد لا يكون
فقط انه استخدام فقط اللي هو قنوات
قديمه لان اعتقد جزء من المستقبل وجزء من
التحديث وجزء من الاستمرار والديمومه هو
دائما تطلع للمستقبل وايضا
ركب التقنيه والتطور وهذا امر مهم جدا
سواء في مؤسسه اعلاميه او غير مؤسسات
الاعلاميه احنا نتحدث عن هذه وسائل يعني
هناك موجوده المحتوى لكن المتغيره الوسائل
لذلك مهم جدا انه يكون في هناك ايضا رقابه
مستمره للتطوير والتحديث التي تقوده
التقنيه والثوره العلميه والثوره التقنيه
التي تشهدها العالم الصحافه باقيه
والوسائل تتغير يعني
مثلا شكرا انا ما تبقى لدي كثير من الوقت
اشكرك جزيل الشكر من لندن مساعد رئيس
تحرير صحيفه الشرق الاوسط صحفي زيد بنكمش
شكرا جزيلا لكن نبارك لكم مره اخرى
علاقه الانسان بالمناخ علاقته تعايش فاكله
وشرب ولبس او فاكله وشربه ولبسه الانسان
مرتبط بالتغير المناخي التفاصيل في تقويم
[موسيقى]
علاقتنا بالمناخ علاقه تعايش فنحن لا ناكل
ولا نشرب ولا نلبس ولا نسكن الا على
مجرياته وفي الصباح ننتشي وفي الظهر ننكمش
والكون كله خلق بتناغم وبنسب موزونه ان كل
شيء خلقناه بقدر والانسان منذ القدم حافظ
على عناصر قواعده من الاخلال ليش لانه هو
مصدر حياته حافظ على الماء وعلى النبات
وعلى الحياه الفطريه وهذه هي الثالوث
المعيشي لحياته انا مثل الماء سهل سائق
ومتى احمي هذا وقتل غير اني في زمان من
يكن فيه اذا مال هو المولى
الاجل
[موسيقى]
[تصفيق]
فالانسان منذ القدم حافظ على المياه
والنبات والحياه الفطريه وجعل لها حرمه
فلا تنتهك فبنى السدود وجعل الحمى
للمحافظه عليها والسد هو الحاجز او الحابس
لمياه الشعاب والانهار والاوديه والماء هو
الحياه وجعلنا من الماء كل شيء حي افلا
يؤمنون
[موسيقى]
ختام الرابعه تذكير بابرز عناوينهم
بعد عمليه غزه اسرائيل تنشر بطاريات القبه
الحديديه وتؤكد استعدادها لكل سيناريوهات
الحكومه الباكستانيه تقول بان اعتقال
عمران خان مرتبط بغسيل اموال وحزبه يطالب
باغلاق البلاد
محمله بمواد طبيه وغذائيه بدء تسير رحلات
الجسر الاغاثي السعودي الى السودان
مكافحه المخدرات السعوديه تطيح بثمانيه
وعشرين مروجه لماده الشبو خلال اسبوعين
شكرا لكم لكرم ولطف المتابعه الى اللقاء
لمتابعه المزيد من الاخبار والبرامج
والقصص الانسانيه والوثائقيات والتقارير
الاخباريه لا تنسوا الاشتراك في قناتنا
على يوتيوب الضغط على زر الاعجاب وتفعيل
جرس التنبيهات